ah casually watching a video on youtube
on a computer more powerful than
anything humanity could build a few
decades ago
this progress and all the wonderful
machines you take for granted
are built on a few rare and precious
materials with names like terbium
neodymium
or tantalum getting these rare materials
from the ground into your devices
is ugly the mining industry is
responsible for air and water pollution
and the destruction of entire landscapes
dangerous chemicals like cyanide
sulfuric acid or chlorine are used to
extract the resources
harming biodiversity workers and locals
and rare resources are also political
tools when countries restrict access to
them to get their way but what if we
could replace the mining industry on
earth with a clean process
that can't harm anyone well we can
all we need to do is look up
asteroids are millions of trillions of
tons of rocks
metals and ice leftovers from the cloud
that became the planet
4.5 billion years ago they can be as
small as a meter
or proto-planets the size of entire
countries
most of them are concentrated in the
asteroid belt and the kuiper belt
while hundreds of thousands more do
their own thing between the planets
as space travel is becoming more
feasible scientists and economists have
begun looking at the resources found in
these asteroids
even relatively small metallic asteroids
may contain trillions worth of
industrial and precious metals like
platinum
and bigger asteroids like 16 psyche
could contain enough iron nickel to
cover the world's metal needs for
millions of years
at current market prices the rare raw
materials alone
would be worth quadrillions of dollars
well not really
but technically for example there are
more than 20 million tons of gold in the
ocean's water
worth roughly 750 trillion us dollars
but filtering out the gold would be so
expensive that you'd lose money selling
it
right now asteroid mining has exactly
this problem
it's too expensive to replace mining on
earth billions of dollars worth of
valuable resources in space
are worthless if it costs trillions to
get them
what makes it so hard the principles
behind mining an asteroid are simple
the basic idea is to choose an asteroid
move it to a place where it's easy to
process
and then take it apart to turn into
useful products
unfortunately all of this collides with
fundamental problems humans have yet to
solve
going to space is expensive it costs
thousands of dollars in rocket fuel
for each kilogram just to reach a low
earth orbit
going further out into deep space costs
thousands more
we need cheaper space travel to make
asteroid mining profitable
one solution is to switch from classical
rockets to electric spaceships
we already use electrical rocket engines
for many of the space probes on science
missions
in principle we only need to build
bigger ones while electrical engines are
not powerful enough to fly to space
they require only a tiny amount of fuel
to go very far
once they're in space this means we
don't need to spend a lot of money on
fuel
only to transport fuel into space
this doesn't solve the whole cost
problem but it makes it easier to start
our first mission
now that we have an electric asteroid
mining spaceship we need to find the
right asteroid and get it there
we've already successfully visited
asteroids with space probes and even
collected samples
still to make it easier and cheaper our
first targets will probably be
near earth asteroids asteroids that
orbit well
near earth after a few months of travel
our spaceship finally arrives at our
asteroid
weirdly formed littered with small
impact craters it hasn't changed much
for billions of years
the first thing that needs to be done is
to secure the asteroid and stop it from
spinning
there are multiple ways to do this like
vaporizing material with a laser or
stopping the rotation with thrusters
once we have a stable asteroid we need
to wait orbital mechanics are
complicated but if you push something in
the right direction
at exactly the right moment you can move
very big things with very little force
so we wait for exactly the right moment
our ship fires its thrusters and nudges
the asteroid into a trajectory that
takes it near our moon
the moon is useful because we can borrow
its gravitational pull to put the
asteroid in a stable orbit around
earth which saves even more fuel again
the trip takes months but all the time
since our ship was launched has not been
wasted
the first space mining and processing
equipment has been installed in orbit
and is now carefully moving towards the
asteroid
the processor works very differently
than on earth
giant mirrors focus sunlight and heat up
asteroid rock to boil out the gases
grinders break up the dried rocks into
gravel and dust
and centrifuges separate dents from
light elements
even if we only extract 0.01 percent of
the asteroid's mass in precious metals
this is still several times more than
you'd get from the same amount of ore on
the ground
but what now how do we get our precious
metals safely back to ground
there are a few ways like loading it
into reusable rockets that return to
earth from space
or if our processor contains 3d printers
we can print a faster and cheaper
delivery system
heat shielded capsules filled with gas
bubbles
these can just be dropped into the
oceans where ships tow them away
this could be the starting point of
humanity's first
real steps towards colonizing the solar
system
as our infrastructure and experience
grows our missions get more and more
sophisticated
parts and fuel produced on asteroids
don't have to be launched from earth at
all
the first mining operation makes the
second one easier and so on
while the space industry grows and
precious materials become cheaper
eventually we could stop mining on earth
even the idea of toxic mining down here
might become something
weird and anachronistic like having an
open fire in your living room
landscapes ravaged by pollution will
heal while the technological wonders
we're used to
get cheaper and less toxic to make
none of this is science fiction we don't
need fancy materials or new physics to
make asteroid mining happen
we could start building this future
today all we need
is an initial push
maybe you could also use a little nudge
not to pursue anything as ambitious as
asteroid mining just to try something
new and fun
let us give you some tailwind there we
partnered with skillshare an online
learning community with thousands of
classes in all kinds of creative skills
like graphic design
music photography illustration and
animation
they have something for every skill
level so no matter from where you're
starting there'll be tons of things for
you to explore
if you'd like to take a glimpse behind
the scenes of our animations for example
we've made a couple of skillshare
classes that teach you how we animated
scenes from our videos with video
lessons classes and hands-on projects
or if you'd rather come up with your own
characters to breathe life into we
recommend character illustration
from concept to final artwork by matt
kaufenberg
but it doesn't really matter what you
pick as long as you get started
improve your skills and have some fun
unlimited access to all classes is only
ten dollars a month with an annual
premium membership
but we have a treat for the first one
thousand cutsces art viewers to click
the link in the description
you'll get a two-month trial for free if
you want to leave your comfort zone by
exploring new skills
and support kurzgesagt give it a try
[Music]